[Music]
in a world where audiences will only
show up for marvel movies netflix will
hire some marvel directors marvel
writers and marvel actors to marvelize
the spy genre by let's say about 15
percent you must be lloyd what gave it
away the white pants the trash dash it's
just
it leans lloyd oh yeah give me that good
snark i get at your glib
the gray man
the russos went from directing
[Music]
being
this
to directing this
and then
cherry
yay now the rubros are back armed with
the rights to one of those books your
dad buys at the airport but instead of
falling asleep on a neck pillow after
two chapters in a ginger ale you'll fall
asleep on your couch while netflix burns
200 million bucks in the background
pink sauce gross
you've seen ryan gosling play a cool
silent driver
cool silent astronaut
and cool silent future detective
but you've never seen him play a cool
silent criminal before have you
okay cool silent criminal turned off the
book cia assassin how's that they made
me stay in bed
how long they make you stay in bed for
quite a long time several weeks actually
oh i hope you're okay better now six
thanks for asking thrill as he
transforms into sierra six a character
who lives in that gray area between
jason bourne and jason bourne with mono
that's the most sleep i've had in 36
hours need anything
just a nap and follow along as he kicks
ass from baku
to monaco to chiang mai to london to
hong kong to vienna to berlin to croatia
to prague to washington dc
wow those are big titles while we learn
bits and pieces of his mysterious
criminal past my father fancied himself
for real macho man and uh
he started laying into my brother so
wait all he did was shoot his dad he's a
florida man that's like nothing
screw kang make the next big marvel
video in florida man
hot on his trail is stupid sexy flanders
wait i mean lloyd handsome no i mean
lloyd hanson god those kicks are
distracting
chris evans shines as america's ass
who clearly watched a bunch of nick cage
to prefer the job would someone mind
shooting the man handcuffed to the bench
cause i got shot in the ass suzanne two
r s t u v w x y three morons
follow the relentless game of dead and
mouse as six must risk his life to save
his ex boss's niece i think and uncover
a horrible truth the cia has done some
shady stuff in the past we're going to
prison for this no you really aren't
this committee and myself have decided
to exonerate the three of you on this
affair see
strap in for action scenes that push the
boundaries of how much smoke and debris
you can hide the action behind
that cuts around like a taken three
editor on ritalin
with the occasional clearly shot scene
to show that yeah gosling does have
moves
all this other crap is on purpose
you know not bad but how would it look
with some random drone shots mixed in
like they're being attacked by a bird
got it
enter a world shrouded in mystery
raising tons of unanswered questions for
the already greenlit sequels like why is
jessica henwick stuck in the person
behind a bank of monitor's role why did
bridgeton leave his hit show to take the
other person behind a bank of monitor's
role why do all the spies keep exploding
boring
since when did likes gone become a
personality trait bubblicious watermelon
wave what do you say there is no other
kind or you can just go with the
buffalicious jesus no that's just
bubbling can someone go to harvard
without forcing it into every
conversation i went from harvard to
analysis to the do's desk in eight years
no one goes to harvard to play football
you did we all went to harvard together
and wouldn't this have worked better if
renee harlan directed it in the 90s with
like christian slater and john travolta
yeah come on you know it would be
so now that netflix is in a desperate
search for the next mega hit they're
throwing everything they've got at a
franchise that's like bond without the
style below seven was taken mission
impossible without the real stuns
and marvel without the ip yeah
that stings because at their core
netflix knows they're just one bad
quarter away from becoming red box
without the p smell
starring
gray man oh wow
fighter of the white man oh wow
captain america and foreign policy
anna
fitzroy and the tantrums cringer 10
iron pissed that was the best acting
i've ever seen wait ucia contractors are
killing people that's it i'm out i don't
care about the money anymore these are
not honorable people and okay i
surrender haha
okay
okay right all right you got me
wait please don't shoot
born again
[Music]
every grade a wet team from here to
reykjavik will be vying for the prestige
of killing the infamous sierra 6.
there's your spin-off the icelandic team
no one believes in until the world is
overrun by elves and ferry oh crap i
just pitched bright too didn't i never
mind
i'm epic voice guy and i'm here to party
lieutenant uhura establish
communications
suffering succotash
hi i'm saul goodman did you know that
you have rights the constitution says
you do